[Music]
Europe's nationalist wave has arrived in
Spain the Vox party secured 12 seats in
Andalusia a region with a high rate of
both unemployment and migration the
party's president is confident they can
now take their regional games to the
national level and illusions once again
have made history
they have shaken off 36 years of
socialist regimes paving the way for the
rest of Spain by saying that it's
possible and even easy to do the same in
the rest of the country the election has
severely weakened the governing
socialists although they secured the
most seats they fell short of a majority
despite this they're vowing to stop the
rise of the far-right an alternative for
Andalusians does not mean that our
government will become a reflection of
this right-wing party which is
xenophobic and justifies violence
against women and amongst citizens ever
since the end of Francisco Franco's
dictatorship in 1975 the Socialists have
dominated Spanish politics but Sunday's
election has shaken the status quo the
ballot was the first major test for
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez who leads a
minority government and with a host of
elections coming up in 2019 Spain's
socialists face a crucial year okay
let's gaze these Spanish the threat to
the Spanish socialist right now to do
that I'm joined by DWS pablo foley alias
in madrid hello there Pablo the
far-right Vox party expected to do well
in this election but it outperformed
expectations in this very key regional
vote what was behind that you're
absolutely right it's being described
here as a meteoric rise of Fox and of
course let's not forget that Andalusia
is the most populous region in Spain so
it's come as a major shock here in May
in Spain and for many Spaniards and
particularly the government of Pedro
Sanchez - two main reasons that Vox
seemed to have have appealed to many
voters in the South say of
is immigration let's not forget that
under Lufia is the main entry point for
many of the migrants arriving onto
Spanish shores that seems to be one of
the topics that worries people down
there and quite a lot and and also let's
not forget that the Catalan independence
question has also sparked this sort of
wave of new nationalism we'll say and
this new sentiment in Spain or renewed
sentiment over the centralization of the
country and that too much power has been
handed over to the regions in Spain
Spain of course in there is made up very
similarly to many other federal
countries such as Germany divided into
autonomous regions and Andalusia also
has one or other major crisis which is
of course very high levels of
unemployment they still stand at over 20
percent and Voxx seems to have struck a
chord with many of the voters who have
blamed the Spanish government for all
those issues that I've just mentioned
before okay Pablo with these three
points in mind do you think we could be
looking at a far-right surge in Spain at
the national level well as I said before
it's been a major shock and if you
actually look at the the latest figures
coming from associate sociological
research carried out in Spain every few
months by a public entity and Vox
actually only has one percent support
nationally now saying that going into
these regional elections in Andalusia it
was expected that they would only have
about four or five percent and it
appears that many voters were hesitant
to say that they would actually vote for
Vox because of the read of the the fact
that they're so blatantly
anti-immigrant and also have some will
say policies that would be deemed ultra
conservative so it'll be interesting to
see how they have a fair in the regional
elections which are going to be taking
place in many of the autonomous regions
next May in particular a big election
year in Spain Pablo Foley alias thanks
very much for that